Okay, let's do one of these, like,
things as a mom that I just don't really care about.
So while I get ready. So let's start.
Number one for me is I don't really care if my kid gets dirty outside.
Playing outside, I don't really care.
Um, I. Again,
I don't know. It's not really a big deal to me.
I save the nose for the things that actually matter.
Not for if they get dirty muddy.
I actually encourage that.
Um, and I.
I would much rather my kid be dirty from playing outside
then all clean from, um,
all clean from being inside all day.
So this one kind of ties in with the first one.
But I do not care if my kid gets her clothes full of stains.
I don't care from eating or whatever.
I don't care. I will clean it later.
There's a washing machine.
I have a stain remover. Like,
it's not the end of the world for me.
And again, I save the nose for the things that actually matter.
Third one is I don't really care for, like,
a strict bedtime. Like,
we sort of have, like,
a rhythm, I would say,
not a routine. Like, yeah,
we do this, put on clothes, like, um,
read books, like,
whatever that is. But I don't have, like,
you need to be in bed by this exact time.
That's just not. Not me at all.
I'm not crazy into that. And that's Just unrealistic,
because, honestly,
it's just
everyone falls asleep when they feel like they need to fall asleep.
Um, not saying that my kids.
I'm gonna let my kids stay up until 3:00am if they wanted to,
but I'm also not gonna be like, oh,
you gotta be in bed at this time every day.
Okay, this one, um,
is. Might be a little controversial,
but I. We do eat our nutrients,
like, diet,
and, like,
all the foods in the. In our house are not.
You guys, I don't buy, like,
I honestly don't even really buy processed snacks,
and when I do, it's all, like,
organic and clean ingredients.
Um, and it's usually for when we're on the go,
not for when we're at home.
Now we're at a birthday party or somewhere, like,
similar to a birthday party setting,
and there's a cake full of dyes, cupcakes,
things like that. If my kid wants it,
I'm gonna let her have it one day.
It's really not gonna do anything for us.
That's not like that every day,
so it's not gonna do anything for us.
I'm gonna let her have it and enjoy it while she's with the other kids,
and it's not that big of a deal for me.
This one also might be controversial,
but I don't really care if meals aren't finished.
Um,
I'm not gonna serve something different,
not gonna cook a whole different meal.
But if you don't wanna finish your meal,
And you're not hungry, that's totally okay with me.
Um, we don't make meal time a big deal. Um,
or like make a big fuss about not finishing a meal.
Sometimes I don't finish my plate cause I'm just not hungry.
So same thing applies for my child.
This one might be a little bit unpopular,
but I don't really care if, um,
baths are longer. Like,
if my daughter wants to take a longer bath,
I don't really care. Sometimes I like to take a longer shower. Um,
so I don't really care if she wants to take a 30 minute bath,
go ahead, it's fine.
I don't know, it's fine.
And another one is
I don't really care about not like a germophobic or whatever.
Like, oh my god,
you gotta wash your hands or you can't touch that
or I'm not like that at all.
Um, I don't really care
if you touch something that you weren't supposed to touch,
and it may be gross to some people,
it's fine. Like,
that's probably why my kid never gets sick,
cause she's always touching things
that she's not supposed to be touching.
And I'm not like,
you have to wash your hands three times and oh my gosh,
you're like, I'm not like that.
So, yeah.
Okay, last one is,
I don't really care if my kid makes a mess playing with her toys,
as long as it gets picked up by the end of the day.
I Don't really care.
Don't really care. Go off with your toys while I.
It allows me to cook, it allows me to clean and. Yeah.